but are you guys doing good I'm doing
good I haven't seen I haven't finished
the show yet but I watched the first few
episodes and from what I saw
it is incredibly well done and obviously
think besides you guys a lot of credit
goes to Mike and so talk a little bit
about collaborating with Mike on this
thing because it's so unusual to have
someone do you know the whole season you
know one person's if you will vision no
I only wrote it directed it and edited
it I think he was involved with the
Mikey produce it real yeah how how you
can wear that many hats yeah but it was
also one of the one of the things that
excited me about becoming part of this
because when a director gets the
opportunity to direct all 10 episodes he
gets a chance to really give it his
signature and I do think he it was a lot
he was allowed to do that yeah did that
hugely and I think that which is just
you know for actors being able to work
with one person and he was sort of you
know guiding our ship in a way and every
single thing is from his mind every
single detail is thought out from him
and it's kind of you know what's great
as well about Netflix is that they just
kind of let you do what you want to do
and so they kind of gave him this
platform to kind of make what he wanted
and and I think it's I feel like you you
know the show kind of reaps the benefits
of that you know because it's all coming
from one mind we'll talk a little bit
how much did you guys know about the arc
of the season how much were you finding
it out script by script and how do you
typically like to work as some people
loved knowing like everything and
playing it and some people want to read
it script by script I feel yeah I feel
like we all the scripts weren't written
when we first know I mean when we first
started I think the first five were in
but Mike explained to us individually
what was going to happen and then
episode 10 came we were way very late we
like very late
game so it's just going and he was
filming all day editing at night and
then writing the rest of the show on the
weekend and then on top of that and then
shot listing and then on top of that
writing dr. sleep which is his next
movie as well so I'm surprised he's he's
still with us yeah I don't understand
that like I don't want to say that he's
involved with drugs but he likes mic
nights and coma
that was his a sugar and caffeine I'm so
sorry a little bit about memorable
moments from filming is there like a day
or two that you will always remember
focus eight months to shoot this thing
so yeah we've got a couple of I think
that the day that we shot episode six
yeah yeah which we shot like a play I
mean we rehearsed it like a play and we
were doing these 20-minute takes and so
we'd spent weeks just figuring out
camera movements and I'd spent I started
memorizing that episode two months
before because I knew that on the day I
it would be like I could forget it and
my lines and then you ruin the whole
twenty minute take and we go back to the
beginning so it was it was it was I've
never done anything like that no I'm
here that was a spectacular experience
yeah I don't mean to interrupt myself
like my own thing but I I haven't seen
episode six yep oh no no but someone who
works for the site has watched the whole
season and told me I believe it's four
cuts yeah the whole episode and he's
like you need to ask about this episode
yeah so I'm glad you brought it up but
so is the episode 100 in like an hour
and 20 minutes is it like an hour
I think the episode runs about an hour
wait so not all those cuts are twenty
minutes got it okay the first one I
think we did was about 18 that's really
long Oh completely
yeah the other one is like 20 20 minutes
something like that oh really yeah yeah
yeah one the way
oh that one broke the dolly yes the
other thing is that when we were
shooting it we we only had Mike came in
and we did through three takes on the 24
minute and it gets very intense and
heated in the scene yeah and and there's
so many camera moves and the Dolly's
moving and standing steady cameras turn
into a ritual and Mike came in just
before the third taken said this is the
one goes all the range and then they
went to turn the thing on the dolly and
the sister mechanism it's like broke and
so we wouldn't have been able to get
another take that was it it was just
like we had three three goes at it and
it literally the dolly broke the minute
after we cut did you know about that
Mike wanted to pull this off because
it's very ambitious for any for anybody
to try to do takes like this yeah it was
written that way and but but I thought
well we're never gonna do that
I kept thinking we're not gonna do that
that's insane how will we do that
we don't have time to do rehearse that
and in camera moves and you know and
then we did it yeah I really cannot wait
to watch it
um what is it like there's a scene in
the first two episodes were you doing
like an autopsy I don't want to say
about the specifics but you're ripping
apart of body throwing stuff on the
ground I had to look away from the
screen because it was that's not for me
like we've seen blood and guts and yeah
not for me either right so what is it
like filming a scene like that
even though you know it's fake below
yeah but it didn't look or feel faked on
set I mean we were I was I was ripping
open a chest cavity taking organs out of
a body you know opening pulling eyelids
back I mean it was pulling the scalp up
and sewing it on I mean it was it was it
was burned into my psyche in a way that
I you know you had a real mortician yeah
we had a real mortician who plays my
assistant her name is Brittany and she
was a pleasure
yeah that's Britney the real mortician
and boy the stories but yeah it was it
was pretty weed we got into every detail
it was so specific which I love that
Mike wanted to do that to show the real
work of fixing a body and and doing the
makeup and taking out the organs and
embalming and putting the embalming
fluid and all these things that you
never ever should think or you know know
about and now I do
oh yeah I think I already have to go but
just real quick the incredible sets
these things were like they looked so
amazing on screen just real quick about
that really yeah
Mike as well he's so careful about every
like I said before his attention to
detail it's crazy there's this wallpaper
in Hill House which now you can't see on
there there's wallpaper from warehouse
that add in he'll ask that has face in
it and you only can see it if you look
at it long enough you start to see a
face emerge and so stuff like that that
he he kind of he peppers these things
throughout the show that the you know on
all the statues they move that statues
move halfway through take so you don't
necessarily realize when you're first
watching it if Yuri watch it you see so
he's just kind of genius in that respect
I gotta go I'm congrats on what I've
seen so far cannot wait to finish the
show thank you
you